imply that should be the case i think he
says i don't support marriage the way
the laws are today laws are today right
yeah
but then
how else would you
suggest raising children
you can get married um without the
government
like um in the church yeah
it's probably i mean i don't i don't
really have a suggestion i think someone
should run for office and change the
laws but how do you get the laws to
change
if the government caters to women um
i don't know i i think like because i
don't know when i just think of it from
a practical perspective i just think
until men stop getting married the laws
won't change
but then it's kind of weird though
they'll still like make men legally
married because then there's they put in
laws that if you live with a girl for so
long yeah so it's like it's like men try
to walk away and then
it's like the government makes them do
it anyway so it's just kind of a shitty
system to be honest um
yeah i don't know i think that's why he
doesn't give prescriptions because there
really isn't a good one
there isn't a good one but there is he
does have an example of something that
worked right and again it might not
necessarily work for him for what he did
might not necessarily work for everyone
but it might still work for a lot more
people than mm-hmm and is out there so
obviously he's he says he's a very
christian man right uh-huh i don't think
he he no he doesn't he actually no
no i'm telling you he says he i'll i
will
he says there's like a clip of him and
he says i don't follow a particular
religion i would say he literally writes
in his book about the fact that he's um
he believes in the full resurrection of
jesus christ okay yeah okay and um
obviously which to me
and i think even when he wrote the last
thing i don't think he follows a
particular church though maybe not yeah
i just mean christian is what okay
you say like
yeah yeah um but you know
again considering it's worked out so
well for him you know going through the
life of having that rockstar lifestyle
and then
finding finding jesus and then
now it turns out he's been married for
20
years it's worked out really well for
him it turns out that
within religion when two religious
people get together and they're actually
practicing the faith again marriage is
lost last longer
why isn't that something that he
preaches if that's
do you think that do you think that
works for everyone i don't like i said i
don't think it will work for everybody
that's why he doesn't preach it but none
of the stuff he says will work for
everyone that's that's but that's why he
doesn't give prescriptions he says these
are the tools but this is what i said i
don't think he's given order to us
because this isn't something he talks
about yeah i don't know i think that's
just like common sense but like if
you're religious pair up with a
religious person but like my parents
have been married i don't know 30 years
and my dad's not particularly religious
my mom is
like
and so should they go around telling
everyone to do that no i'm just not a
big fan of telling people what to do to
be honest i think everyone thinks they
know everything
cheap yeah very true i think that comes
on to
the next topic
oh that's weird because people have
started requesting advice sessions from
me
and it's hard because i'm like why
i'm like i mean if they they wanted that
bat like because they what they want to
pay i've been thinking about this lately
i'm like they want to pay for it but
then i can't say i don't give advice
oh you might as well get to get a bag
i guess but i think this comes on to
the next topic i want to talk about um
which is specifically
the current pillars i'd say of the red
pool movement so that would be the
andrew the uh
fresh and fit roller to marcy
no because i look at everything through
an entertainment perspective because
that's like i would consider myself an
entertainer yeah and i just think
they're very entertaining i don't think
you're wrong yeah i do think they're
very entertaining
however okay i think
the problem i have with someone like
sneaker like i said
he's a very
entertaining person i watched a lot of
his videos he's so entertaining he's
such a good interviewer too yeah he's a
good interviewer yeah i think i do think
over the last
couple months i do think his interview
and prowess have reduced a bit
um
but i think that's because he's going a
bit angry
and so does it doesn't tend to be as
patient as he used to be yeah but
i think he he's the same as me so he's
he's 24 this year and
um
a problem with social media these days
is the fact that
this is the first generation in which
people who
don't come from um rich families and to
actually make wealth themselves
there's a there's now a generation of
people who didn't have to become
competent to become successful right and
so even though he's commenting when it
comes to you know youtube and
what he does
i don't think he's as well read
uncertain
certain concepts when it comes to red
pill and so you'll see him go on fresh
and fit or debate people i would agree
with that yeah you'll see him debate
people and his arguments fall apart
because he's unable to substantiate what
he said no it's weird it's like i know
what he's trying to say but yeah
but he doesn't say yeah yeah but it
comes with time you have to be bad to
get good of course of course i
definitely agree with that and but my my
main thing i wanted to say that is
people i think people like this again
and andrew tate again i think is an
exceptionally smart man based on what
he's he's done he's been able to take
over the internet however the one time
he's actually pushed by someone who's
maybe more intellectual than he is
his arguments completely failed and he
divulged he um devolved into
what what what can i have an example so
basically he was um he had an interview
with hasanah the hassan abby i'm not
sure if you know i don't know so he's
like a political um
uh youtuber streamer
and
um hassan was basically um speaking to
him about a
a thing that he said about women being
bad drivers right
and then he was basically saying well
the stat song was always saying the
stats showed that women actually better
drivers than men
it's actually he was wrong
women drive less than when that's why
they're less insured so they actually
like they pulled it back because that's
what happens a lot they'll disprove him
but they don't show the entirety of the
stat so in that case it's women drive
less than men and therefore they have
less accidents but they actually have
more accidents based on how much they
drive and i would say like i don't know
there's just some things like
anecdotally i would believe
because like come on you're telling me
come on well i mean i've never been an
accident so
no i just think every time i there's
someone driving crazy it's always a girl
no like
every time i've been like cut off crazy
it's always some girl she's on her phone
she's not paying attention like but the
thing is men men do make up the best and
the worst of society never in every
single uh strata so even with driving
the best drivers and worst drivers i'm
just telling you by and large he was
correct okay they misrepresented that
stat and it was the same thing like he
he did that with an iq where like they
were yeah with that one yeah they picked
one woman who was like third on the list
rather than yeah yeah like like so a lot
of times they'll disprove him with a
stat where they don't like talk about
the entirety of the stat yeah it's like
the same thing with the body count like
you'd say oh that's the average moment
that's like okay but when you include 80
year old woman sure yeah
but the main thing i wanted to say with
that was instead of being able to
explain his point you know explain why
he was right he devolved into what women
on fresh and fit do you where to be like
well i feel like this is my truth and so
my truth is is is true which is
literally what he ended up saying he was
like my truth is that women um drive
drive worse and i i think
that's the main one of the main problems
i have with these people is that
a lot of the stuff they they say women
they claim women do they end up doing
the same thing the moment is any form of
pushback by someone who seems to be more
intellectual than they are
so how is it that
you can
have this energy or say this they have a
standard for people the example you gave
you was right no no i get what you mean
oh it's like i'd have to have a
different example i think i think what
they're saying is like okay i could see
10 studies telling me that the earth is
flat but if i look up in the earth this
round like i think it's round